so there's something called the sexy sun
hypothesis I love it already yeah and it
suggests basically that what women are
trying to do is find fathers that are
going to give them attractive Sons
because attractive sons are more likely
to have kids I think that what you see
here is maybe an inbuilt biological
mechanism that women have which is a
predisposition to make their sons
attractive to Future women and they have
deep down in understanding that the more
prestigious and domineering men on
average have better mating outcomes
remember what we are we are
grandchildren optimizing machines that's
what humans are we're not children
optimizing machines we are grandchildren
optimizing machines and once you get two
generations away from you away you go
crack